hey what is the sky ISM kabhi HD here
and Twitter is so important like it's a
platform it's like YouTube it gives
millions of people a voice I use Twitter
all the time your favorite people
probably use Twitter all the time it's
like a cultural phenomenon if you think
about it oh you're not perfect Twitter
there are definitely things that I've
mentioned that I would change about
Twitter in the past in videos and in
tweets so I can expand on those things
and maybe you'll agree dear Twitter many
of us would generally like to see things
in chronological order now I know RSS is
dead and it's a cool thing to do now to
try to predict what the user wants to
see and put it up at the top you know
Facebook does it Instagram does
everything's all out of order now
Twitter is just so pure just like a
straight-up timeline and Twitter is
super time-sensitive probably the most
time sensitive of any social media so
that's part of the reason I use a third
party Twitter app to guarantee that I
read tweets in order as they happen it
doesn't like seeing a one-day-old post
right above a two-day-old post right
above a 45 second old post so at least
when I press that show less often button
could you actually make it show that
less often
please dear Twitter stop hobbling third
party app so for those who don't know
Twitter has sort of a history of making
it difficult to develop a good Twitter
app there's something called a token
limit which is essentially a sealing to
how many people can use a certain
Twitter app and once you reach that
number of users the app becomes useless
to new users you can't login it
literally doesn't work so several apps
I've used have fallen victim to this
really all it takes is the app getting
really popular it reaches that maximum
number of users and instead and that's
happened with stockin that's happened
with Android apps Mac apps iOS apps it's
just kind of a pain so if you're going
to do this you would think Twitter oh
they must be working really hard on
their own stock Twitter app the first
party Twitter app must be great again I
don't think I've seen a good update to
the Twitter for Mac app in months so
Twitter either stop being so developer
and user hostile at the same time by
hobbling third party apps or make your
first party apps way better or both dear
Twitter bring back at replies like the
way they were three or four months ago
it was just better that way your Twitter
let us edit tweets it is 2017 and we
have a giant machine digging a tunnel
under Los Angeles to build an actual
Hyperloop but we still can add a tweet
we have the Large Hadron Collider we
found the god particle we still can edit
tweet now look I know there's a lot of
cases against editing tweets and I get
them you know what if what if you post
something really great and it gets a ton
of retweets and then you edit it to
something heinous and terrible if you
tweet something nice at a celebrity and
then they retweet it and you go edit
your tweet to say something really mean
and then everyone sees it maybe this
guy's on to something what if you get a
million retweets for a hilarious comment
then a company pays you to edit the
content of the tweet to essentially
advertise on a million people's Twitter
feeds then Twitter becomes oversaturated
with sponsored tweets people get sick of
it and Twitter loses all credibility
you know what anything is possible so
here is the case for editing tweets you
post something on Twitter and within a
little bit you notice it has a typo in
it so you can edit the tweet within 60
seconds of posting it and any tweet
that's been edited has a little
indicator and Twitter will show the edit
history of any edited tweet so you can
click that little indicator it expands
everyone can see it
boom clean done so this solves pretty
much any of the downsides that there may
be to editing tweets you know people
make typos they happen this is literally
just to fix that the half-life of a
tweet is really short like much shorter
than a lot of other things on the
internet and that's already really short
so that means most of the activity
happening on a tweet is happening within
the first few minutes sometimes seconds
that have been posted so deleting and
rewriting a tweet sounds like it works
great for maybe most tweets but the most
time-sensitive ones where the most
activity is happening really quick you
know 45 seconds and 3000 retweets later
you notice a word is misspelled do you
delete that tweet like honestly do you
delete it like that little edit button
just for that would be so nice and look
in case you still think tweet editing
might be a bad thing let me introduce
you to a couple other social networks
that you may have heard of that also let
you edit post Facebook there's an edit
post button full time not just for typos
so anyone can edit any post ever and if
you share a post then someone edits it
it will show up in your shared
post reddit is actually a perfect
example in the comments you have up to
three minutes or until your comment gets
three replies to edit that comment
without getting an asterisk so you can
edit a comment whenever but if it has
engagement then it has an asterisk and
everyone knows it's been edited
Instagram you can edit everything
caption tags whatever Google Plus same
deal right here on YouTube you can
literally edit YouTube videos to add a
blur to a subject to correct something
without deleting the video it saves that
the same URL and the video is changed
Vimeo you can literally replace entire
video files at the same URL in Vimeo you
can upload a completely different video
with the same title and everything and
it stays so editing tweets doesn't seem
that insane anymore just saying I think
you got this Twitter you got this so you
have it at the end of the day I think
it's pretty obvious that Twitter could
do none of these things and they
continue to make crazy decisions all the
time but we all just keep using Twitter
anyway I'm going to keep tweeting you
can follow me if you want that's pretty
obvious but these things would make us
just so much happier on the Internet and
that's never a bad thing
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching coffee has the next one please
[Music]